[موسيقى]
مساء الخير اهلا بكم الى نشره الرابعه من
الرياض نبداها بالعناوين
الغليان في اسرائيل يستمر لبيد يدعو
المتظاهرين بعدم التوقف وخطاب مرتقب لنا
الدنيا
خامس ايام رمضان توافد مستمر للمعتمرين
وتخصيص اربعه عشر الف عامل ومراقب
للعمليات المسانده
رابعه تتجول في المعرض والمتحف الدولي
للسيره النبويه 25 جناحا تعريفيا بست لغات
في رابعه ايضا
موعد التبرعات المشبوهه يتجدد جهه حكوميه
سعوديه تحذر من التعامل مع التبرعات
الابار
حاله من الغليان تعيش اسرائيل حول
التغييرات القضائيه واقاله وزير الدفاع
في اخر التطورات لا تزالوا حشود
المتظاهرين تملا الساحات في القدس ورملا
فضلا عن تل ابيب صحباء محاولات من الشرطه
لمنع المتظاهرين زعيم المعارضه في كلمه
القاها وسط المتظاهرين على عدم التراجع
قبل ان يكون لاسرائيل دستور مكتوب على حد
دق على حد قوله ومن جهته دعا رئيس الوزراء
بنمينه المتظاهرين في القدس الى تجنب
العنف في وقت نصح فيه بعض المستشارين
نتنياهو بتاجيل خطابه حتى معرفه حجم
التظاهرات الليله مراسله العربيه فادت بان
نتنياهو قد يؤجل خطابه الى اجل غير مسمى
قبل ذلك بحسب تصريحات نقلتها وسائل واعلام
اسرائيليه قال رئيس الوزراء بنيامين
نتنياهو انه يواجه حمله دعائيه سلبيه ضد
التعديلات القضائيه التي يتجه لتعليقها
واشار الى ان المحتجين وطنيون لكنهم لا
يفهمون لاصلاح الذي يدعو اليه وذكرت قناه
12 الاسرائيليه ان مقربين من نتنياهو
نصحوه بالتعجيل بخطاب لتهدئه الشارع
في تراجع المفاجئ اكد وزير العدل
الاسرائيلي يريف ليفين انه سيحترم اي قرار
يتخذ رئيس الوزراء بنيامين نتنياهو بشان
مستقبل التعديلات القضائيه مضيفا بان
الافتقار الى الوحده في الحكومه يمكن ان
يطيح بها وقال ليفين في بيان له انه اقتنع
بامكانيه تعليق التعديلات الدستوريه مشيرا
الى ان اصرار كل فرد في الحكومه على موقفه
سيؤدي الى اسقاطها وانهيار الائتلاف
الحاكم
[تصفيق]
وقد طلب حزب العمل المعارض في اسرائيل بحل
الكنيسه الاسرائيلي متهما حكومه رئيس
الوزراء بنيامين نتنياهو بانها جعلت
الكنيست رهينه لخطتها المتطرفه طالب حزب
العمل المعارض بوقف ما سماه جنون حكومه
نتنياهو في اشاره الى التعديلات القضائيه
افادت وسائل اعلام اسرائيليه بان الحكومه
الائتلافيه التي يتزعمها رئيس الوزراء
الاسرائيلي باليمين نتنياهو نجت من اقتراح
بسحب الثقه قدمته المعارضه احتجاجا على
خطه الاصلاح القضائي حيث اعلن رئيس
الكنيست ان المقترح رفض باغلبيه 59 صوتا
مقابل موافقه 53 ومن جهه اخرى فهذا مراسل
العربيه بوقوع اشتباكات بين الامن
ومحتاجين وسطت تل ابيب واغلاق العديد من
الطرق الرئيسيه
وقد ابارت رساله لرقابه العاملين في وزاره
الخارجات الاسرائيليه ان السفارات في
انحاء العالم تلقت تعليمات بالانضمام الى
اضراب اليوم الاثنين ضد خطه التعديلات
القضائيه لرئيس الوزراء بنيامين نتنياهو
واشارت رساله الى انشطه وزاره الخارجيه في
اسرائيل وخارجها ستقتصر على خدمه الطوارئ
فقط
[موسيقى]
من الناصره في فلسطين ينضم الينا المحلل
السياسي النظير مجلي السيد نظير مرحبا بك
معنا هل يستطيع
سيد نظير بن بن يمينه في خطابه المرتقب
ان يعالج المشكله
عميقه جدا التي تعاني منها اسرائيل هذه
الليله
مساء الخير لك عزيزي وللاخوه المشاهدين
والمشاهدات لا ليس سهلا على ان يواجه هذه
المشكله ولن ياتي بحلول الجذريه وسيحاول
ان يؤجل
التشريعات لانه محكوم بايدي
حلفائه الذين عقد صفقه معهم هم يدعمونه في
مواجهه قضيه الفساد التي يحاكم فيها في
المحكمه المركزيه في القدس وهو يدعم القطط
التي ياتون بها لتغيير منظومه الحكم في
اسرائيل وليس فقط اصلاحات للقضاء ولذلك هو
محكوم بهذه الرغبه لكن
موجه الاحتجاز غير المتوقعه التي
صارت في الشارع خلال كل هذه الاسابيع 12
اسبوعا على التوالي
والانفجار الذي حصل امس بعدما اعلن
نتنياهو عن اقاله
او نيته اقالته لم يقله بعد حتى الان ولكن
عن نيته اقالته خرجت الجماهير بشكل عقلي
في مختلف الاماكن 150 الف ان امضوا كل هذه
الليله في الشوارع احتجاجا على هذه الخطوه
فهذا هز داخل الليكود من داخله واصبح هناك
ضغط على نتنياهو ليس فقط من الشارع بل من
داخل الحزبي هنالك من بدا يتمرد ويؤيد
الجللا ضد نتنياهو هذا الامر جعله يحاول
ان يؤجل لكن بالمقابل هبه الاحتجاجيه هي
هبه قويه تعبر عن الدوله العميقه في
المجتمع الاسرائيلي التي تصر على فرد
اجهده ثانيه لم يعودوا يكتفوا لا بالتجميد
الخطه اين يمكن ان تتجه الازمه في
سيناريوهاتها سيد نظير بالنسبه للشارع
المحتج
الى اي مدى يمكن ان يصل ما السقف الذي
يمكن ان يطالب به في هذه الاحتجاجات وهل
سيكتفي
باي موقف للحكومه او نتنياهو ام سيصاعد
وماذا عن موقف بنيامين نتنياهو يعني
وحكومته كيف يمكن النظر الى مجمل هذه
الاوضاع
الموجه الاحتجاج وقاده الاحتجاج الذين
يختلفون عن القياده السياسيه المعارضه في
اسرائيل
لديهم موقف مبدئي لن نكتفي بشطب هذه القطه
الان نريد الدستورا يضمن لنا ان لا تاتي
حكومه غدا او بعد غد وتغير القوانين فهم
يريدون الدستور هذا الطلب لم يكن يتبناه
احد في المعارضه الاسرائيليه يعني يعير
لقيت كان يتحدث عن امكانيات حوار الان مثل
ما تفضلتم في تقريركم بالمقدمه يتحدث عن
دستور لاول مره لان قياده احتجاج طردت على
لقيت وفرضت على جانس ان يطرحها قضيه
الدستور وهذا يعني ان الامور من جهه
المحتجين لن تنتهي ولن تتوقف عند اي حد
السقف مفتوح وهم يقولون انهم سيواصلون
حمله الاحتجاج حتى لو استمرت اربع سنوات
عندما تسقط العكومه وطبعا هم سيحاول ان
تسقط الحكومه قبل ذلك لاننا نتحدث عن قوه
كبيره في المجتمع الاسرائيلي نتحدث عن
الجيش ونتحدث عن الشرطه والمخابرات
والمؤسسه القضائيه والمؤسسه الاقتصاديه
رجال الاعمال النقابات ان نتحدث عن
المؤسسه الاكاديميه نتحدث عن صناعه
الهايتيك كل هذه القوه تملك مفاتيح اساسيه
في المجتمع الاسرائيلي لذلك انا اسميها
الدوله العميقه وهي تقف موحده ضد هذه
الحكومه واجراءاتها لانها تعرف ان هذه
الحكومه جاءت لتحدث هذا التغيير الجوهري
في نظام الحكم في اسرائيل وهذه مساله ليست
من اليوم بالمناسبه هذه يشتغلون عليها في
اليمين منذ 18 عاما
[موسيقى]
العلاقه بين نتنياهو وبين
الجيش بعد بعد اقاله قلنت
هل اهتزت هل يمكن الحديث عن شرق الان في
هذه العلاقه بين بين بين
حكومه نتنياهو بين وزاره الدفاع الجيش
الاسرائيلي
اولا هذا الشرح قائم منذ سنه 2011 وليس
اليوم عندما طلب نتنياهو خطه للهجوم على
ايران وكان الجيش غير مستعد لذلك ورفض
القطه وطالب بميزانيات هائله لكي يستعد
لمثل هذه الحرب وعلى مدى سنوات العشر التي
تلت هذه الفتره كان نتنياهو يحرض على
الجيش وعلى قياده الجيش كل المواقع
الاخباريه والمواقع البحثيه التي يمتلكها
اليمين في اسرائيل كانت بشكل منهجي تحارب
الجيش تتهمه بالتبذير وتتهمه بالتنازل عن
عقيده القتال والمواجهه والاقدام وغير ذلك
ولذلك كان هنالك شرق وان نتنياهو يتهم
الجيش بانه حاول الاطاحه به في الانتخابات
الاخيره
وليس صدفه ان نجد نتنياهو يعير نتنياهو
اتهم الولايات المتحده بدعم هذه القطه
لانقلاب على حكومه نتنياهو ويتهمون الحمله
الاعتزاز الحاليه بهذا الشكل لذلك الشرق
قائم يتعمق اكثر من هم بالشارع هم يمثلون
ايضا الجيش هيئه رئاسه اركان الجيش
الاسرائيلي اجتمعت اليوم للبحث عن الضرر
الامني الذي تحدده تحدثه هذه القطه
وقرارات الحكومه مما يعني ان هو كبير
ولذلك من الصعب ان يتخيل المراه الان ان
يتراجع نتنياهو ويحدث مصالحه مع الجيش بعد
عشر سنوات من الدم الاسود الذي جرى بينهما
تعبير البيت الابيض عن حاله من القلق
وخشيه كذلك على تداعيات هذه الازمه على
الامن القومي بالنسبه
لاسرائيل ما هي دلالاته سيد نظير
اولا في الولايات المتحده توجد قوه يعني
من يحكم هو الحزب الديمقراطي وتوجد قوه
كبيره لليهود الامريكيين في هذا الحزب
وتاثير بالغ وهؤلاء يخشون على اسرائيل من
اسرائيل يعتبرون سياسه نتنياهو مدمره
للمشروع الصهيوني يخشون على الشعب اليهودي
ومستقبله من وراء هذه السياسه خصوصا وانهم
يلاحظون ان هذه السياسه جاءت لخدمه اهداف
شخصيه عندنا تنياهو الذي اقام صفقه مع قوه
اخرى لدي ايضا مصالح شبيه وضمن التغيرات
في القوانين التي ياتي بها نتنياهو قوانين
فرض قوانين شريعه يهوديه على
وتفضيل على القوانين المدنيه هكذا يريد
حلفائه الحريدين وهذا يعني عمليا ابعاد
اليهود الامريكان عن اليهوديه بالنسبه
اليهم هم غالبيتهم اصلاحيون ولذلك يشعرون
بانهم سيفقدون انتمائهم اليهود لنتيجه
لهذه السياسي ولذلك هذا الامر يؤثر على
الاداره الامريكيه فضلا عن الرؤيه
الاستراتيجيه الامنيه الولايات المتحده
تقيم علاقات بالاساس مع المؤسسه العسكريه
الامنيه ويوجد انسجام تامه بين المؤسستين
في واشنطن وتل ابيب وهذا يصب ايضا في
المعركه التي يقودونها في مواجهه نتنياهو
للضغط وهذا فضلا عن انهم لا يحب
قد ادار حربا ضد الحزب الديمقراطي والرئيس
يذكر تماما تلك الفتره لانه كان نائبا
للرئيس واليوم يشعر بان نتنياهو اصبح عبئا
وليسا مساعدا او حنيفا من الممكن ان ياخذه
فعين الاعتبار في معاركه وقضاياها شكرا
جزيلا لك من الناصره المحلل السياسي نظير
مجلي
شكرا
نذكر مره اخرى بتطورات الاوضاع الميدانيه
في اسرائيل نشاهد الان في هذه الصور
المباشر
الاحتجاجات ضد التغييرات القضائيه واقاله
وزير
الدفاعات مستمره لا تزال حشود المتظاهرين
تزيد وتملا الساحات في القدس ورام الله
فضلا عن تل ابيب ايضا هناك محاولات من
الشرطه لمنع المتظاهرين كشفت الشرطه
الاسرائيليه عن 80 الف متظاهر على الاقل
يطوقون الكنيست نذهب الى الكنيسه من امامه
التحديدا تنضم الينا مراسله العربيه لانك
الغاصي لانا مرحبا بك ما هي اخر التطورات
الحشود تستمر في التواجد في هذه الساعات
اهلا بك يعني فعليا الحشود تتزايد منذ
صباح اليوم يتوافد عشرات الالاف من مدن
مختلفه الى القدس من تل ابيب من حيفا من
بئر السبع من مناطق مختلفه قاموا باستخدام
ايضا القطارات العامه للتوجه الى القدس
والتجمع هنا كما ترون امام الكنيست يعني
ان استطاع ايضا عبد مساعدتي حتى تقومون
برؤيه اعداد كبيره من المتظاهرين الان هم
خرجوا ضد هذه التعديلات القضائيه وضد
نتنياهو حتى يعني على ما يبدو ان ايضا
هناك غضب ولكن في نفس الوقت شعور
بالانتصار من قبل هؤلاء المتظاهرين حيث
يعني باتت مطالبهم يعني
باتت مطالبهم فعليا تتجه الى التنفيذ هناك
مخاوف مخاوف كبيره في الحكومه الاسرائيليه
الان ويعني محاوله لاقناع نتنياهو بالخروج
والاعلان ربما تاجيل هذه التعديلات
القضائيه ولكن المتظاهرين يقولون بانهم لن
يرضوا فقط بتاجيل هذه التعديلات القضائيه
الى ما بعد الاعياد اليهوديه او حتى بعد
استقلال اسرائيل اي بعد شهر من الان ولكن
هم يقولون نحن نريد الغاء هذه التعديلات
القضائيه بشكل نهائي لان هذه التعديلات
القضائيه من شانها ان تؤدي اسرائيل حسب ما
وصفوها يعني تعديلات الديكتاتوريه
وايضا كان هناك اضراب شامل او اضراب في
عديد من المجالات انضم عدد من الطلاب من
الجامعات ايضا من البنوك من التعليم هناك
عمال ايضا من ماكدونالدز وهو ايضا شركه
عالميه يعرفها الجميع قاموا باغلاق
متاجرهم لمده اربع ساعات في جميع انحاء
بلاد البلاد يعني نحن نتحدث ايضا الى
انضمام وكان هنا مطار بن غوريون الدولي
الى هذا الاضراب ايضا نتحدث عن اضراب في
مجالات مختلفه الجامعات الاسرائيليه عدد
منها ايضا انضموا الى هذه المظاهرات يعني
على ما يبدو
طيب دون فقدنا الاتصال شكرا جزيلا عموما
لمراسله العربيه لانك الغسيل كانت معنا من
امام الكنيسه الاسرائيليه في الرابعه بعد
قليل جوله في المعرض والمتحف الدولي لسيره
النبويه 25 جناحا تاريخيا بسته لغات
اهلا بكم من جديد تحتضن المدينه المنوره
المعرض والمتحف الدولي للسيره النبويه
الذي يعنى بالتعريف الشامل لسيره النبي
صلى الله عليه وسلم
زويل سلطان السلمي ياخذنا في هذه الجوله
لنتعرف اكثر على هذا المعرض ضمن سلسله من
الحرمين
[موسيقى]
300 باحث من مختلف الدول الاسلاميه
قطو 17 عاما من البحث والتوثيق وجمع
المصادر العلميه الموثوقه لكتابه المحتوى
الخاص لسيره المصطفى وهجرته والاحداث التي
مرت عليه في معرض السيره النبويه والحضاره
الاسلاميه في المدينه المنوره كما نشاهد
نلاحظ من خلال هذا المتحف عده اقسام من
اهمها قسم الله عز وجل اهل الثناء والمجد
كل ما يتعلق عن الله عز وجل واسمائه
وصفاته ثم قسم الانبياء وكانك تراهم ثم
قسم النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم وكانك تراه
من خلال ادابه ثم النبي صلى الله عليه
وسلم وكانك معه في مكه والمدينه ثم قسم
المراه والطفل في الاسلام ثم بعد ذلك
ياتيك المتحف والتقنيات المعاصره الموجوده
في هذا المعرض المعرض مجسمات تقدم
وصفا مرئيا لطريق هجره النبي من مكه الى
المدينه وابرز المواقع التي مر بها
والاحداث التي صاحبت هجرته ويتيح لزائريه
مشاهده مجسمات تقريبيه صممت بشكل وصفي
لتجسده الطبيعه العمرانيه
والمعالم الطبيعيه للمدينتين في عهد النبي
المعرض راعي جميع فئات المجتمع جميع
الاديان جميع الاعمار كذلك سواء الرجال او
نساء مسلمين وغير المسلمين كذلك اهتم
المتحف بالماده العلميه المجموعه والمحكمه
والمفارسه عبر احدث التقنيات واحدث العلوم
يحتوي المعرض على وسائل عرض متطوره وحديثه
لعرض الحقائق والمعلومات المتعلقه بسنه
وسيره النبي محمد وتقديمها للزوار من خلال
اليات مبتكره في البرمجه والهيكله
والتبويب والتصنيف بطرق عرض عصريه متعدده
من المدينه المنوره سلطان السلمي العربيه
[موسيقى]
توافد مستمر واعداد كبيره للمعتمرين في
خامس ايام شهر رمضان المبارك امانه
العاصمه المقدسه نشرت نحو ثلاثه عشر
الفعام فضلا عن الف مراقب لتنفيذ خطتها
الموسميه منذ دخول شهر رمضان عبر تقديم
خدماتها في تشغيل وصيانه ونضافه ونضافه
المرافق البلديه ومتابعه جاهزيتها
بالاضافه الى العمل على شبكات الطرق
والانفاق والاناره والحدائق وغيرها من
الخدمات
من الحرم المكي ينضم الينا مراسل العربيه
عبد الواحد الحميد من احد شوارع مكه
المكرمه
اهلا وسهلا عبد الواحد ايضا حدثنا اليوم
عن الصوره في مكه المكرمه كيف تبدو في
اليوم الخامس من ايام شهر رمضان المبارك
اهلا وسهلا بك طبعا فيما يتعلق باليوم
الخامس نحن نقف الان في المنطقه المركزيه
المحاذيه للمسجد الحرام حيث هناك حركه
كبيره بعد صلاه العصر حيث تبدا الحركه
بشكل مستمر في المنطقه المركزيه في اوقات
الصلوات تحديدا فيما يتعلق
بامانه العاصمه المقدسه التي تقوم بتنفيذ
خطتها الموسميه
لموسم العمره هذا العام حيث تعمل الامانه
بشكل مستمر على توزيع
المراقبين الصحيين وكذلك توزيع الجهود
بشكل عام في مختلف احياء مكه المكرمه ينضم
الينا اسامه زيتوني وهو متحدث امانه
العاصمه المقدسه اهلا وسهلا بك استاذ
اسامه نريد ان نتعرف اكثر على ملامح الخطه
لهذا العام اهلا وسهلا بك اخي الكريم
بالتاكيد منذ اليوم الاول من هذا الشهر
الكريم امانه العاصمه المقدسه استنفرت
كافه الطاقات او امكاناتها البشريه
والاليه لتقديم افضل الخدمات لضيوف الرحمن
وزوار هذه المدينه المقدسه حيث كانت
الامانه قد وضعت خطه وبرنامج عمل لادائها
خلال هذا الموسم هذه الخطه او برنامج
العمل تضمنت جميع الجوانب الخدمات البلديه
بدون استثناء على سبيل المثال هناك جانب
خدمات النظافه العامه ورفع وازاله
النفايات خصصت فيه الامانه ما يقارب من 13
الف عامل نظافه موزعين في مكه المكرمه مع
تركيز السواد الاعظم منهم في المنطقه
المركزيه بالاضافه الى جانب اخر مهم وهو
جانب
الرقابه على المطاعم والاسواق والتاكد من
توفر المواد الغذائيه بطرق صحيه وامنه
وفحص العينات في المختبرات المخصصه
الى الى جانب ايضا الجانب مهم وهو متابعه
المرافق البلديه واقصد بالمرافق البلديه
شبكه الطرق والانفاق والجسور في مكه
المكرمه والتي تستقبل في هذه الايام ارسال
كبيره جدا من السيارات لذلك شكلت لها
الامانه يعني فرق كبيره ومخصصه من
المهندسين والفنيين للتاكد من كفاءه
تشغيلها خلال الموسم بجوده عاليه ان شاء
الله استاذ اسامه نريد ان نعرف ما الفرق
بين خطتكم لهذا العام بالمقارنه مع خطط
السنوات الماضيه نعرف ان السنه هذه هناك
اعداد اكبر من المعتمرين
مع الكثافه العدديه الموجوده في هذه
المنطقه شكرا جزيلا لك الاستاذ اسامه
زيتوني المتحدث الرسمي لامانه العاصمه
المقدسه على كل هذه التفاصيل التي اطلعتنا
عليها هذه هي ابرز تفاصيل الخطه الموسميه
التي تقوم عليها اماره العاصمه المقدسه في
هذا العام خالد شكرا جزيلا لك عبد الواحد
عبد الحميد مراسل العربيه من مكه المكرمه
الرابعه ايضا مستمره فيها بعد قليل قبالنا
على تحويل المزارع الى نزول ريفيه سياحيه
في عنيزه في وسط السعوديه
[موسيقى]
غليان اسرائيلي يستمر لبيد يدعو
المتظاهرين لعدم التوقف وخطاب المرتقى
في خامس ايام رمضان التوافد مستمر
للمعتمرين وتخصيص اربعه عشر الف عامل
ومراقب للعمليات المسانده
الرابع تتجول في المعرض والمتحف الدولي
للسيره النبويه 25 جناحا تاريخيا ب 6 لغات
موعد التبرعات المشبوهه يتجدد جهات حكوميه
سعوديه تحذر من التعامل مع التبرعات الابر
اهلا بكم من جديد حضرت جهات الحكوميه
سعوديه عده من التبرع عبر منشاه مخالفه
تدعي حصولها على الترخيص مشدده على ان
المشاركه فيها تورط صاحبها وتعرضه
للمسائله
رئاسه امن الدوله في السعوديه تقول بان
الاستجابه لدعوات جمع الاموال او المشاركه
فيها تعرض صاحبها للمسائله النيابه العامه
السعوديه تقول بانه يحضر استغلال تداعيات
العمل الانساني في دعوات لجمع اموال
التبرعات بقصد التمويه او اخفاء اموال غير
مشروعه وغسلها تحت غطاء العمل الخيري كما
تقتصر الاعمال الانسانيه على الجهات
الرسميه المختصه وزاره الداخليه السعوديه
تقول بان جمع التبرعات بدون ترخيص عمل
مخالف للانظمه ومنها نظام مكافحه الارهاب
وتمويله
وزاره التجاره السعوديه حذرت ايضا من
التعامل مع منشات تزعم ترخيصها وتدعو
للتبرع وجمع الاموال مقابل حفر ابار
المياه في الخارج مركز الملك سلمان
للاغاثه قال نحن الجهه الوحيده التي تتولى
تسليم اي تبرعات اغاثيه او خيريه او
انسانيه سواء كان مصدرها حكوميا او اهليا
لايصالها الى محتاجها في الاستوديو ينضم
الينا المحامي والمستشار القانون الدكتور
اسامه القحطاني دكتور اسامه حياك الله
تتجدد التحذيرات مره اخرى من كثير من
الجهات من التبرع لجهات مجهوله ايضا
التي تدعي
المساهمه في العمل الخيري
لمن لمن نشوف هذه التحذيرات التي تتجدد كل
فتره يعني هذا مدى يعني اولا تعني بانه
زياده هذه العمليات عمليات النصب
والاحتيال والتبرعات ايضا لهذه الجهه
مرتبط ايضا بالفتره التي نعيشها على حاليا
نحن في رمضان تعرف الناس تكون مقبله على
فعل الخير
والبحث عن اوجه الانفاق في الخير والى
اخره فربما كان مرتبط بهذا الجانب اكثر
والحقيقه ان المشكله هنا هي ليست في في
هناك
عقوبات رادعه كثيره جدا هناك نظام قوي
هناك هناك مراقبه عاليه ولكن المشكله في
وعي الناس عندما شخص يقوم بالتبرع لاي شخص
لشخص لا يعرفه او قد يعرفه لكن لا يعرف
اين يتصرف بهذه الاموال هنا مشكله كبيره
جدا يتعرض الكثير من الناس لعدد من من
الاشكاليات القانونيه وربما يتعرض للسجن
او الغرامه الكبيره
عندما جزء منها هناك من خلال التاريخ
القريب هناك كثير من هذه التبرعات ذهبت
لارهاب مثلا
او ذهبت لغسيل اموال وما الى ذلك او حتى
ربما الى فساد شخصي مثلا الى استيلاء على
هذه الاموال والى اخره وهناك قصص كثير جدا
وناس بريئون ليس لهم اي علاقه الا با يعني
في قصص احداها مثلا شخص اعرفه جيدا بسبب
علاقه قرابه مع شخص تبرع بمبلغ وفي
النهايه قال هو ايضا الى سجل لان ذهبت
مباشره الى اعمال ارهابيه في فترات اللي
كانت في في ارهاب لدينا
فلماذا يعرض الانسان نفسه لمثل هذه
المسؤوليه الكبيره
وهناك اوجه
مرخصه ورسميه يمكنك من خلالها تقديم العون
المباشر او من خلال معرفتك الشخصيه لماذا
لا تتبرع الا من خلال شخص ياخذ منطبق حتى
على الجهه الخارجيه التبرعات للابار وبناء
الابار والاحتيال اللي يحصل فيها يعني
طبعا التبرع للجهه الخارجيه هنا هنا خطوره
لانه المنع من الجمع ايضا يحضر اي جمع
لاعمال خارج المملكه الا من خلال جهه
رسميه مرخصه وتحتاج ايضا لترخيص اخر اذا
كانت تبرع لشيء خارج المملكه
وهناك جهات كثيره مرخصه لدى لدينا في سواء
في المملكه او حتى على المستوى الخليج
وغيره
لسنا بحاجه لان نبحث عن اشخاص ربما بكلمات
او بخطبه عاطفية يستدر عواطف الناس من
خلالها ويذكر بعض
التبرع للجهات الخارجيه دكتور اسامه يعني
وخاصه مساله الابار يعني يجيك واحد مثلا
يعطيك بير باسمك اليوم يتغير بيصير باسم
ثاني يعني التبرع لهذه الجهات ايضا وش
مخاطرها وتبعاتها اللي ممكن تعرض هذا
المتبرع للمساءل مع الحقيقه بخاطرها كبير
جدا يعني من كاليات في مثل هذا النوع اللي
تحدثت عن الخالدي اللي هو حفر الابار على
سبيل المثال هذه من الاشياء التي لا يمكن
كانت تراك ما تستطيع ان تتبع اين ذهب
المال حفر بئر في اي مكان العالم قد يكون
محفور قديما قد يكون حفر شخص اخر
ممكن هذه الصوره تتوزع مع اكثر من شخص
بامكان يعني لا يوجد اليه للتحقق الا من
خلال جهه رسميه
وب التجربه هناك الكثير من الاموال التي
تم التصرف فيها بهذا الشكل وهي في الحقيقه
لم تنفذ على ارض الواقع او انه اسيء
استغلالها
وهي قصص كثيره جدا يعني وايضا هناك وسائل
رسميه تستطيع ان تتبرع من خلالها يعني او
ان تذهب بنفسك يا اخي ولكن ان تعطي هذه
الاموال لاشخاص قد لا تكون معرفتك بهم
كافيه
لدرجه ان ان تعرض نفسك ايضا للمخاطره بدلا
من البحث عن الخير ان تعرض نفسك ايضا
للمخاطره انها قد تذهب الى ارهاب او الى
شخص لديه اشياء اعمال مشبوهه من غسل
الاموال او اي امر مشابه او حتى استغلال
وهذا حصل انه هناك جمعيات حتى كثيره اغلقت
بسبب وجود اما اعمال ارتبطت باعمال مشوبه
بالارهاب او ايضا الاستغلال والتصرف بهذه
الاموال من قبل هؤلاء الذين يجمعون
الاموال هذول الناس اللي يتبرعوا الدكتور
اسامه التقيت فيهم ببعضهم يعني اكيد ليش
الاصرار مثلا على انهم يذهبوا الى هذه
الجهات مع انه في جهه مضمونه ومامونه
[موسيقى]
ويحذر حتى من اكثر من الجهات ليش وهما ناس
حتى واعيين وفاهمين وعارفين فبالتالي ليش
الاصرار على الذهاب الى هذه الجهه عدم
ثقافه مثلا في الجهه الاخرى
الحكوميه ولا ايش بالضبط لا اعتقد اتصور
يعني هي
الى اخره فلماذا تضع نفسك في مثل هذا
الامر اما ان تقوم العمل بالعمل بنفسك او
ان تذهب من خلال المؤسسات الرسميه اشكرك
شكر جزيلا شكرا
القحطاني المحامي والمستشار القانوني شكرا
لك الله يحفظك
تعيش مدينه عنيزه في وسط السعوديه حيث حول
عدد من اصحاب المزارع مواقعهم الى نزل
بهدف استقطاب السياح والزوار والاستفاده
من الدعم والتسهيلات المقدمه لهم من قبل
وزاره السياحه وصندوق التنميه السياحي
منطقه القصيم تعد منطقه غنيه بالمواقع
الزراعيه والمقومات التي من شانها
المساهمه في تفعيل السياحه الريفيه
عبد الرحمن العصيمي ينضم الينا من مدينه
عنيزه في القصيم حياك الله عبد الرحمن من
احد النزول الريفيه راح يعرفنا عليه بشكل
اكبر تفضل يا عبد الرحمن
يا هلا بك خالد حياك الله وكل عام وانت
بخير فعلا اقبال كبير من اهالي عنيزه
وايضا من اهالي منطقه القصيم وايضا من
السياح سواء السعوديين او حتى الخليجيين
على السياحه الريفيه في منطقه القصيم التي
تتميز بمزارعها الكبيره امير منطقه القصيم
قبل ايام عقد اجتماعا للجنه السياحيه في
المنطقه لتعزيز السياحه الريفيه في مستقبل
الايام الان الاستاذ ابراهيم طوير ابو عبد
الله احد المستثمرين في القطاع السياحه
الريفيه ابو عبد الله اولا خلينا نتكلم عن
الاقبال انت يمكن لك سنه وشوي فاتح
المزرعه هذه كيف شفت الاقبال حتى الان
وسهلا بكم اولا وشرفتونا الاقبال جدا جميل
يعني عدد كبير من داخل منطقه القصيم ومن
خارج المنطقه وعلى مستوى الدول الخليج
قاعده تتوسع ما شاء الله كل شوي قاعده
تتوسع بسبب الاقبال الكبير على المزرعه
الحمد لله الان في توسع وفي اقبال ما شاء
الله كبير
من دول الخليج على السياحه الريفيه طبعا
انت ما شاء الله يا خالد زي ما انتم
شايفين البنوته الصغيره هذه قاعد تحلب
البقره طبعا هذه بنت ابو عبد الله ملوكه
ملاك طبعا انت بناتك واولادك شغالين معك
في المزرعه نعم نعم هم مشغلين معي
بالمزرعه وساكن انا اصلا بالمزرعه وما شاء
الله متعلمين مع الزراعه والحلب والعنايه
بجميع الحيوانات داخل المزرعه كيف تشوف
ردود فعل الناس لما يجون تشوفون عائلتك
معك شغاله وقاعد تحاول يعني تعلمهم مثل
هذه المهن الاصيله والقديمه الصحيحه اعجاب
الكثير من الزوار
شلون
بالزراعه العيال ما شاء الله بالدخل
المزرعه متعاونين يعني يقول هذه حياتنا
اول يعني
ما شاء الله وهذا اللي معها طبعا حبيبتها
هالله هالله طبعا خالد ايضا المزرعه هنا
تقدم وجبات يعني اكل للزوار طبعا قبل
رمضان في افطار صباحي واليوم في رمضان
انتم ايضا عندكم افطار رمضان الان نجهزه
ونستقبل الزوار وكل شيء يجهز قدامهم ينشر
وسمبوسه خبز بيتزا كله موجود يعني انت
الحين تقدم تجربه زراعيه رائعه للزوار
بتجربه يشوفون الحيوانات يشوفون العشائر
يقطفون الفواكه والثمار وايضا تقدم لهم
يعني وجبه غذائيه ريفيه نعم بوجبه غذائيه
ريفيه والاجمل من كذا انه كل شيء يصلح
قدامك وتشوفه قدامك
ابو عبد الله نعم الله الله
في الافطار اليوم بنقدم اللي هو الشوربه
ونقدم
السمبوسه خالد مدخلي في الاستديو شخص اكيد
يحب الاكل فلازم تاخذ راحتك بالوصف وهو
صايم بعد فنب نجوع الزياده فخذ راحتك
بالوصف طبعا من الفرن على طول على الطاوله
على الزبون في الزعتر السمبوسه التاوه
الشوربه الفول
القهوه والشهر البدوع يعني قدمت فطور
وبايدك تطبخي جره الفول وراك انت حولت
شغفك بالطبخ طبعا ان شاء الله تنفور يا
خالد وراي فول مدمس فول الله فول جره نعم
خالد زي ما انت شايف يعني أبو عبد الله
قصه ملهمه وناجحه حول شغفه وكمل الطبخ
ولزراعه الى مكان
ممكن
يقيم يوم يومين فيها ولا شلون
المزرعه الله يحييه والله يشرفنا واعز مين
يجينا والله خلاص يا خالد تعال انت بس
امورك طيبه ما راح يقول الاسعار يعني عندك
واسطه خلاص
لا طبعا هي متاحه متاحه هي للزوار يحجزون
عن طريق التليفون الواتساب ويجون يستمتعون
بالاجواء بكل اريحيه ممتاز يعطيك العافيه
وشكرا جزيلا لك عبد الرحمن على الجوله
الطويرب ريفا
ريفا
قريبا نزوركم ان شاء الله شكرا لك وشكرا
لضيفك وتمنياتنا لكم بالتوفيق
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
تتفاوت ساعات الصيام بين دوله واخرى
ومدينه وثانيه ليش لان الارض كرويه وان
شعاع الشمس مائل وبما اننا قريبين من نقطه
الاعتدال الربيعي فان فتره الصيام ستكون
متقاربه على جميع الدول تقريبا فاقل فتره
صيام في اول رمضان واطول فتره صيام في اخر
رمضان ليش لان رمضان كل يوم يزيد دقيقه
تقريبا وبما ان الشمس تقع الان شمال خط
الاستواء فان المواقع الجغرافيه الواقعه
شمال خط الاستواء ستشهد اطول صياما
بالعالم والمواقع الجغرافيه الواقعه جنوب
خط الاستواء ستشهد اقل صياما بالعالم حصن
صيامك بالسكوت عن الخناء اطبق على عينيك
بالاجفان لا تمشي ذا وجهين بين الورى شر
البريه من له
وجهاني
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
اطول ساعات صيام على مستوى العالم ستكون
على النرويج واقريل لاند وفنلندا تصل
قرابه 23 ساعه واقل فتره صيام بالعالم
ستكون على جزر القمر وجنوب افريقيا
والارجنتين تصل قرابه 12 ساعه والدول
العربيه تتفاوت بين 14 الى 15 ساعه واطول
فتره صيام على الدول العربيه ستكون على
الجزائر وتونس تصل قرابه 16 ساعه رمضان
واقبل ياء للالباب فاستقبلوه بعد طول غياب
عام مضى من عمرنا في غفله فتنبهوا فالعمر
ظل سحاب
[موسيقى]
اسرائيل يستمر يدعو المتظاهرين لعدم
التوقف وخطاب مرتقب لنتناعه
رمضان توافد مستمر للمعتمرين وتخصيص اربعه
عشر الف عامل ومراقب للعمليات المسانده
الرابعه تتجول في المعرض والمتحف الدولي
للسيره النبويه 25 جناحا تعريفيا بسته
لغات
وموعد التبرعات المشبوهه يتجدد جهه
الحكوميه سعوديه تحذر من التعامل مع
التبرعات الابر
الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]